direction l'espagne à présent qui a
adopté hier à la loi trans c'est une
première en europe elle permet à tous
les adolescents de 16 ans et plus de
changer de genre et de nom les
précisions sur place de notre envoyé
spécial leslie cinglant c'est un jour
historique a déclaré rainer monteiro la
ministre espagnole de l'egalité toujours
selon ses propres mots le pays avant
gardiste en europe
le gouvernement espagnol a approuvé la
loi transe comme elle est appelée ici en
espagne
elle permet de changer de genre et de
noms dès l'âge de 14 ans la loi permet
donc la libre détermination de
l'identité de genre alors plus
précisément cette loi supprime
l'obligation d'effectuer des tests
médicaux et psychologiques ainsi qu'une
prise d'hormones pour pouvoir changer de
genre
l'objectif est que les personnes
transgenres puisse choisir librement qui
elles sont alors en cas de conflit avec
des parents un adolescent pourra même
faire appel un défenseur judiciaire et
dès l'âge de 16 ans le consentement des
parents n'est plus nécessaire alors la
ministre de l'egalité irene monteiro a
indiqué que face aux agressions subies à
toutes les personnes ayant peur pour
leur intégrité
l'espagne souhaite envoyer un message
fort je vous propose de l'écouter et hop
et non sur la même terre
je crois que non seulement nous lançons
un message fort de défense et de
protection des droits de tous et en
particulier de la communauté lgbt y ait
des personnes trans
mais nous lançons aussi un message fort
à l'europe car la base du projet
européen est précisément les droits
humains et la garantie de la liberté la
dignité et le bonheur de tous peu
importe qui on est et qui on aime et
amène à qena mais le texte suscite la
polémique au sein des mouvements
féministes et des conservateurs du
partido popular de son côté l'extrême
droite de vox a déclaré dans un
communiqué il ne sera pas permis aux
enfants d'être endoctrinés ou confus en
prétendant qu'ils peuvent choisir leur
sexe ou réaliser des opérations ou
thérapie hormonale le parti souhaite
amener la loi devant le tribunal
constitutionnel